I'm sure you guys think this was gonna
come so the US government Mike Pompeo
saying that they might actually ban
picked on you know it was populist
probably the most popular app right now
right right
tik-tok and why would they they ban it
give the Chinese government can get
access to everyone's information yep you
know collects dinner just like most of
our caste right so they're worried that
the data will be grabbed by the Chinese
government
Kanye's part yeah so they're actually
considering banning that actual app
which is popular right now well we have
to just invent our own app I don't think
you want the Chinese government getting
into everybody's American phone s
tick-tocks big with the younger audience
right it's not you know a lot of adults
are on they're definitely younger but
then now we're getting on it celebrities
stars older stars you're on it but it's
also like you don't know what they can
if they can use spy technology to use
the phone to watch other things going on
there your government could show and you
have a child and that's tick-tock so
they're actually worried that the
Chinese go to the will just seize that
information and take it away from those
people they're you know that the users
but yeah I think all our apps are pretty
much assessable to that to get in
trouble for that and they passed the law
in California now they can't really do
that and also they're there there's an
American artist I know he wouldn't want
to make sure you want to melt you would
want to make sure there's nothing like
that happens but of course the
government's going to be really really
something else
hey Brennan you look like you're on an
alter mer you sacrifice people my
basement well I got that you worship is
that really worship Savior
I mean I can if you want well you have
candles there dude they're goth candles
what the [ __ ] is going on I don't know
yeah these are those are those made from
[Music]
now art that art is the big that's a big
Nintendo controller or or is it or is it
just a maze to get closer to the
Beelzebul are you to worship Elsa Bob no
I'll tell you this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]